[Music]
thank you very much
so should we encourage the abandonment
of the traditional hierarchical
stiff-upper-lip culture that once
embedded privilege and power of course
all and should we welcome and necessary
shift towards hearing and supporting the
vulnerable or should we perhaps be wary
of a focus on weakness and victim hoods
which risks undermining the individuals
involved and damaging social cohesion
well this is what we're going to talk
about today is it the end of a stiff
upper lip is this a good thing or is it
a bad thing and we have a fantastic
panel I think to talk about this so on
my right is Peter Tatchell the human
rights campaigner and very brave
campaigner for gay rights who's been
arrested more times than I can probably
remember exactly meanest salami on my
left - is the founder of the
award-winning blog Mazzara politan which
connects feminism with critical
reflections on contemporary culture from
Africa centered perspective and Mena you
were named as one of the twelve women
changing the world by Elle magazine
along with Michelle Obama and Angelina
Jolie and on my far left metaphorically
and not sorry not much vertically but
literally once as David you're on a
[ __ ] she was once a communist but is
not now you describe yourself as a
radical moderate am i right and it's a
very good and well renowned columnist
for The Times and has won all sorts of
awards there so we're going to start
first of all each of them is going to
give us two or three minutes of their
pitch on the question of should we
welcome leaving a stiff upper-lip
culture behind
first of all Peter I want to jump
straight in to tackle the issue about
identity politics because it's often
portrayed by critics as being the
politics of victimhood but I would say
in fact ideally politics is the politics
of equality and so
justice why did identity politics come
into existence it came into existence
because sections of our society felt
marginalized and excluded it was a
reaction to the fact that because people
belong to a particular race or belief
system a gender or sexuality or
disability group their issues were not
being heard the mainstream political
consensus was not attuned to the rights
of women ethnic minorities LGBT us
people disabled people until identity
politics co-organized those groups to
campaign for their rights so it was a
very necessary process to redress
graving justices that have been more
ignored by the mainstream of course I
want to add the qualification that as
much as I defend identity politics I
also want to defend and succor the
mutual bond that unites us to emphasize
the importance of also recognizing our
common humanity
well sections of society quite rightly
fight their corner we also need to
acknowledge the things that unites us
the things where we can work together
the fact that unity and solidarity is
the only way to secure effective lasting
and universal change good thank you
Nina thank you so I'd like to address
the description of the debate as well as
a response of the question so first of
all the suggestion that identity
politics draws from misfortune is one
that I find itself to be unfortunate
groups of people coming together to
address systemic oppression and systemic
injustice doesn't really have to do with
misfortune and secondly if there's any
group in society that has had
to be psychologically resilient and
stoic and persistent it is actually not
the powerful and the privileged who tend
to be predominantly male and
predominantly whites and predominantly
belonging to the elite class by contrast
this is these are groups who are very
fortunate women as a group who are
accused of being the weaker sex are
actually more self-sufficient than men
as a group from the moment that a boy is
born he has to he depends on women to
feed him to cater to him to nurture him
to nourish him and this goes on
throughout his life whereas young girls
are taught from a very early age to be
able to do these things for ourselves
and needless to say people of African
heritage people of Asian heritage and
other people of color have had to bite
their upper lips very firmly in order to
survive in this world so in my view
vulnerability is actually a very
privileged emotion to be order to be
able to express vulnerability requires
that you feel that you have a solid
foundation which means that you have
time to cultivate a kind of sensibility
and sensitivity where you can express
your vulnerability so to respond to the
question I think that yes we should we
should encourage a stiff-upper-lip
culture but by we I am talking about
women I'm talking about people of color
sorry I think we should leave it behind
but women and people of color black
people LGBT communities trans people all
of the disenfranchised we should be
allowed to express our vulnerabilities
more because we are the people whose
voices have been suppressed for so long
[Applause]
David I think I'd rather mistaken what
the title of the session was I I thought
there's victims and warriors with an e
as I'm one of the Warriors I'm very very
worried as to I'm sure you're right
about boys Mina but you never met my
mother I'm sure that exception I took
this actually discussion to be I won't
take it in a slightly different
direction as well as the ones work with
where it's gone what we've been talking
about a little bit and hinting about is
what people have begun to call identity
politics funnily enough when I looked at
the prospectus I understood it to be
about what you might call therapy
culture the idea that is a relatively
new one that each of us has a series of
vulnerabilities and potential problems
which are the consequence and necessary
consequence of being human that it is a
good idea or a bad idea for us to
acknowledge and to seek to take action
about and the way I was going to think
about this in the first instance was to
say that this in terms of Britain at
least has been very much a generational
question in other words if you do get
two people from different generations
they will take very different attitudes
towards it indeed and I just want to
point you towards one specific date
which I think a number of you were
sentient for a number of you very
scented for maybe a few of you weren't
born for which is the night of October
the 31st September the 1st 1997
who can tell me what happened on that
night Princess Diana crashed a car
crashed into interval now the reason why
in Paris the reason why I raised this
one particular was because what then
happened publicly
we had never seen or we said we had
never seen anything like it in this
country before and the reaction of
certain people to it particularly
majesty the queen who is enormous ly
highly regarded not least by least my
people who would previously have
regarded the monarchy in a negative
light
was thought to be incredibly deficient
in what we would probably describe now
as empathy or the expression of emotion
and too many people watching the scenes
immediately after Princess Diana died
what was generally called the outpouring
of grief completely wrong footage quite
large numbers of people because they
found themselves living in an emotional
universe that they hadn't realized
actually existed
one which had been created if you like
out of the war and out of the period of
austerity the period of one of my
mother's absolute favorite phrases to me
was and to us was don't make a fuss
don't make a fuss don't say anything
boys don't cry we were told boys don't
cry that's not a lie that's not
something of an exaggeration that's what
we were told to be that thing was not to
express that thing now in that sense I'm
not trying to make how all boys with
victims because they couldn't express
themselves by crime what I'm trying to
point out is we have undergone a
fundamental change about our attitude or
we are undergoing about what it is if
you like it is permissible or to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas